you know the next two to three weeks are
gonna tell us a lot they're gonna tell
us if the health care system completely
collapses they're going to tell us if
you know probably if we're heading into
more of a severe lockdown something that
looks or they're not that looks it is a
martial law these things are all on the
table I don't know that we have to freak
out about them so you don't really have
control over them but the idea of you
know the election getting pushed back or
being canceled the idea that you know
come November people are not going to be
able or feel comfortable voting getting
the other you know all of these things
are gonna change our lives for a
foreseeable period it's not conspiracy
mongering to say that we are you know in
you know the survival of the country
right now is not guaranteed and I and I
don't I don't say that you know to joke
around and I don't say that to be
dramatic or to be an alarmist the
survival of the country that we are
living in right now in any and by the
way the country in the sense that it
looks or feels like anything you
remember it's not guaranteed it's not
it's truly not and the people at the top
know that we're at the precipice of
something very very challenging and if
you see huge spikes in crime if you see
a global depression if you see a loss of
faith in the government which I don't
know how you don't see more of I think
it's because people are afraid right now
so they're kind of ignoring certain
things the insider trading and stuff
like that I think people are you know
you know burying their heads in the sand
but if you see those things happen I
mean this these are the ingredients that
you know bring about a fall and we see
that and I'm hoping that doesn't happen
and I'm hoping that we're able to
weather it but it is not at all
irresponsible to float those
possibilities because they are real
is a real possibility that your city and
local governments collapse because of
this and that the federal government
then rolls in the tanks and you don't
have any more rights and it's not the
America that you remembered and the rich
go to planned communities where they
have rights and you don't and they have
the technology and they are able to
weather the storm for however long it is
you know and you you know sitting there
in a Perkins you know or a Denny's or
Pizza Hut are not going to weather the
storm because you are going to be left
to unfortunately perish by the people
that you put so much faith in and what
will prevent that bonds with your family
with your friends when the time comes
you know not right now
but when the time comes probably there
will be you know I mean it will be some
time for fun I can't believe I'm even
saying this pose like there might be
some type of organized resistance to
what happens I don't know no you know
it's funny because it's not you know we
have to laugh at these things I mean we
are laughing at them but no if rich
powerful people leave us all to die you
know you might have to go and visit them
I don't know I'm just saying I am NOT
you know I am NOT trying to sound the
alarm here other than to say if you
aren't going over these possibilities
you can ahead what is happening in your
head what is happening in your head I'd
love to know I mean if you're not going
over the real possibility that these
people are gonna pull the ladder up I
don't know what is it the ladder up is
that the expression yeah yeah I don't
know what you think is happening
I don't know what you imagine is gonna
happen
you better hope chloroquine works you
better hope rim des Amir works and this
might be as Rogan said the other day it
might be a dress rehearsal because the
next pandemic oh you know but maybe
maybe we'll be prepared probably not
um I'm gonna be the Hollywood improv
this weekend headlining fuck'em we're
gonna do it we're gonna do it took off
minimum ha ha but those are the hack
jokes that are going on on Instagram
right yeah where people should be taken
out and shot
so I mean be careful the content you put
out be careful the content you consume
you know you know I I wonder how it's
all gonna play out it's very interesting
I you know the one thing that'll save us
this is literally what I believe this is
truly what I believe I think the one
thing that saves us is that the robots
are not good enough yet if the robots
could do all the things these people
wanted Oh goodbye I mean truly if AI and
automation like if AI was at the point
where the AI could do most of what the
wealthy needed done I would be like in
total panic mode I think that we're
still some years from that happening
that might be the only thing that saves
us
it's not about Democrat or Republican
it's not about any of that
it's about this is just a strong survive
in a sense it's just Darwinian and
that's what you're seeing right now is
you're seeing nature you know it was
Chris Hedges said the other day we're in
the middle of those six extinction or
whatever this was a year before this
even happened so I mean I'm not don't
don't be too anxious don't be too
depressed
don't use too many mind-altering
substances stay sober keep your mind
sharp you're going to need it
I'm hoping the worst doesn't happen I'm
cautiously optimistic
only because robot
cannot do all of the jobs yet I don't I
don't think it's you know it's like I
don't I don't I don't I'm not trading on
empathy here I'm like thank God we're a
little behind